In what kind of situations
does the Poisson process arise?
In general, it
arises whenever we
have events like arrivals
that are somewhat rare,
and which happen in a
completely uncoordinated manner,
so that they can show up
at any particular time.
In such situations,
the number of arrivals
will be often described by a
certain distribution called
the Poisson
distribution, and which
is named after the person who
first studied this situation,
who is a famous
French mathematician
by the name of
Simon Denis Poisson.
An early example
where the data seems
to fit the description
of the Poisson process
is a curious one.
It had to do with
deaths from horse
kicks, that is, accidental
deaths, in the Prussian army.
The idea here is that
a death by horse kick
can happen pretty
much at any time.
And different arrivals,
that is, different accidents
are completely uncoordinated
from each other.
So the process is sort
of completely random.
For more scientific
applications,
it was realized that
certain physical phenomena
obey the Poisson process.
Examples are the following.
You have some radioactive
body which decays,
and the decaying
happens once in awhile,
emitting various particles.
Different particles get emitted
at completely random times
in a completely
uncoordinated manner
and, therefore, this
process is actually
described as a Poisson process.
Conversely, if you have
a photo detector who
looks at a very
weak light source.
So photons arrive from that
weak light source one at a time.
And you look at the time at
which photons hit the detector.
Then, the process
of photon arrivals
is very well-modeled
by the Poisson process.
For more modern
applications, if you
look at the financial markets
and the times at which
certain very unexpected events,
like certain market shocks,
occur, a model that
is commonly employed
is to use a Poisson
process model.
Although this is not an
entirely accurate model,
it provides a first approach
to situations like this.
But these days, the
predominant source
of applications for
the Poisson process
is in various
service operations.
You are the phone company.
Phone calls get placed
at random times.
And because there are
several people involved
who are uncoordinated
with each other,
those calls get placed at
completely random times.
And the same story
goes about, let's
say, service requests
to a web server,
service requests to
any kind of company.
So, many applications that
are being studied these days
and which rest on Poisson models
involve service operations
of this type.